Hello I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
And for this video, we've
partnered with Oreo.
Dan, it's been said, that some people
will do anything for an Oreo.
I do like an Oreo.
Can't go wrong with an Oreo.
It's true.
So they got in touch and they asked me
to come up with an anything.
And this is our anything.
Yeah, I had wondered why we were on
this massive platform
above a giant pool of milk.
Does that make me the
Oreo in this situation?
No no, you're not an Oreo.
Okay.
The Oreo is the prize.
This is the treadmill waiter.
The question we're gonna answer Dan,
is would you dress as a waiter
hold a tray full of milk.
Yes, yes.
And run on a treadmill for an Oreo?
I noticed if I don't keep up
I'm just gonna end up eating the...
Yeah.
As long as I get like more than one Oreo.
Or maybe we'll work out
like a scoring system,
rotation, you know, air distance.
Okay, I'll give it a go.
We'll give it a go.
And we'll capture it in
glorious 4k slow motion
as Dan tumbles through the
air into a load of milk.
I'm sorry, what
What?
Look at this.
Oh, this is fancy.
This is a fancy establishment.
I even get a bow tie look at that.
All right, so pop around there
and get that on.
All right.
Just so you know, this isn't real milk.
We didn't really want to waste that much.
So it's just cornstarch and water.
You look the part
Yeah, I think so.
I mean, what kind of
restaurant though serves,
serves drinks in a plastic cup,
but you have to wear
a bow tie as a waiter?
Or more like which restaurant serves milk?
Like which, like table
9 ordered some milk.
That's more down to the
person ordering milk.
Right. Okay.
We'll start slow.
We'll start at one mile an hour.
I'm going to be triggering
the camera here.
And we've also got this little lovely lad.
Who's going to film your
impact on the treadmill.
This is already difficult.
This is not a good sign.
Feeling good about it?
I think so.
We'll start upping the speed.
We're at one and a half.
I'm nervous. I'm like.
A bit wavering slightly.
I've never been this nervous
delivering milk before.
Think about the Oreos Dan,
think about the Oreos.
Okay.
Two and half.
Okay. This is a rapid milk delivery.
You know what? There's a
button that just says 10.
I think we'll just go.
Oh God.
We'll go to 10.
Okay.
Oh, he's doing well.
Try not to spill on the
treadmill Dan, we don't want.
It's only six?
It's only six.
This is 10.
Sounds like a plane taking off.
Aah.
Whoa.
Oh he's gone.
Oh!
Oh my God.
Are you alright, Dan?
How was that?
What happened?
You almost made it to top speed.
Oh, here we go.
So what, how do you feel?
Do you feel like you could
last longer on there?
Honestly it's really difficult.
As soon as you lost one milk.
I felt like it was all over.
Because the milk is in
three separate places.
Yeah.
One milk fell over,
which meant the other
ones were over balanced.
So I was like, I just lost it.
And then I lost my balance.
So I just went.
All right you're dripping on me.
I don't wanna wet a shoe
Oh, I'm sorry.
Are you alright there?
So I did it early
trigger because I noticed
that when the milk went,
it was all over from there.
Yeah. It was hard to
concentrate on what I was doing.
I'm really running here actually.
You're booking it.
Look at this.
This is one of the weirdest
things we've ever filmed.
Look at this.
This is mental.
What a sight this is.
There goes to the first milk.
Oh, it's all over from this point.
That's tipped of the tray off balance.
There goes to the rest of it.
Oh God, my legs had just gone.
You've completely Superman-ed it.
You're mid air falling belly flopping
towards a moving floor.
Oh God.
You can see all the milk
shooting out the end of it.
Oh, there's the impact.
Oh.
Your foot skimmed the
surface and didn't touch.
You were like treading milk for a second.
Like without touching it.
There's the waiter as he goes down.
Is that the tray coming down after me?
That's the tray. Yeah.
All right, let's speed it up a bit.
Okay.
Okay, there's full thing.
First milk goes, that's
really where I lose it,
then I'm just trying to.
The impact was severe.
Ohhhhh.
I did a full one 180,
like I was on my front
and then the thing shot me
outwards, and I was on my back.
What score did I get, you think?
Well, let's, let's analyze it.
So you lost all three milks.
So that's minus three, but I
feel like your impact score.
Yeah.
We'll give you 2 for the air.
I try to like, hold on there.
But I couldn't because
I was like, I was like
I'm losing my balance.
That's two points.
The rotation 180 degrees.
That's 180.
So I think that's 183 points.
So, how many Oreos is 183 points?
Well, do the calculation?
That's four Oreos.
No, it's four and a half.
Four and a half Oreos
Yeah.
That's very good.
Okay.
Let's try.
Let's try and beat the score.
All right.
Oh, I'm really nervous again.
Table 10 has asked for some milk.
They came in and they handed
out hundreds of free Oreos,
now everyone needs the milk.
Well, how come theirs are free
and I have to do this for mine?
That's not fair.
Oh God.
Oh man.
You're not messing about.
So, what's your favorite color Dan?
Oh.
Oh God, Dan you're spilling it everywhere.
Oh, you headbutt your own tray.
I think I got some in my mouth actually.
Oh God.
My foot flicked off the end.
Look at me thumping down here.
You're just in a sea
of milk, that's weird.
That looks weird.
Just being brought back.
Hold on.
If we score this one,
that is 10 points for the headbutt.
Okay.
Four points on impact.
And the rotation not as
much, maybe a 60 points.
Okay.
So that's 12 Oreos.
But I got 180 points last time
and I got four and a half Oreos.
Conversion rates, algebra.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah.
Sure.
Alright Dan, for this one,
the camera is very wide, very low down.
So the, the height of the splash
will be the focus of this one.
Okay.
Let's start you up.
Oh Jesus.
You're getting better at it.
He's rocking it.
He's rocking max.
Look at that, look at the speed.
Oh.
I took some of the
treadmill with me that time.
That was an absolute back slam.
Oh, how'd you do that?
How'd you end up on your back?
I have no idea.
I actually don't know.
Well, let's analyze the footage.
I think you hit your head on it.
I've properly lost it there.
You've absolutely chinned yourself.
Look at that milk coming off there.
Your face is covered in it.
For goodness sake.
Dan, That was amazing.
It wasn't that good.
None of the people got their milk.
Well, no one got any milk,
but excellent bounce.
Excellent rotation.
Yeah
Splash height.
I feel like I was quite
good at it, at the end.
Yeah. Commendable.
Well worth it for the
Oreos, how many did I win?
I think you won about 17 Oreos.
I had 16 and a half
after the first two goes.
Yeah. Then the last one was
it was just a half Oreo, but.
Thank you.
Only 14 in there so I still
owe you one, or a few.
Well, thank you very much
for watching that video.
I enjoyed that.
Hopefully you did too.
Feel free to subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys.
And a big old thanks to Oreo.
Why are you eating when
you didn't do anything?
All right.
Good work, that's good.
What about the ladder?
Can you?